[Musique]
et
merci attendait très chiant dès le 5 à
pilonner ton direct ils exigent la berd
a fêté lundi entre tf1 et la lutte c'est
ma tante au téléphone ce qui bavent
saint-roch ah oui oui il ya maintenant
qui voudrait occuper des problèmes de
chalencon excuse moi j'ai envie même si
c'est ton ami c'est que s'il dit vrai
c'est catastrophique si défaut c'est
catastrophique
dans tous les cas je trouve que c'est
catastrophique les yeux on a choisi un
bouc émissaire qui est pierre jean
chalon victimise je verrai avec mes
avocats
j'avais beaucoup de despres progressiste
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'amis comme
stéphane plaza accepte mais j'avoue que
je suis très triste très triste de la
façon dont on m'a traité c'est une sorte
de guet-apens
cette chouette jeudi nous étions
quelques cassettes des cas s'il y'avait
il y avait neuf casseurs qui se seraient
battus en plaine et sur l'ensemble de la
soirée qui s'est terminée à 22 heures et
on avait dressé des tables c'était
uniquement pour la présentation que le
bicentaire des remèdes apportés aux gt
cuisine depuis quatre mois dont je vois
pas comment j'aurais pu faire des
soirées que je suis quelqu'un de gentil
chat quelqu'un de généreux et quand
j'invite les gens à dîner chez moi c'est
moi qui les ai dit que je dorme en pâtit
il a quand même
il a quand même dit qu'ils avaient des
ministres la wii les manger mais enfin
je veux dire n'importe quoi n'importe
qui et puis derrière il ne serait pas il
n'est pas officiel totalement faux et
calomnieux sur twitter à des gens qui
lisent mes chalencon ça va pas vous avez
pété un plomb quoi alors attention il ya
une enquête qui est ouverte alors déjà
comment ils vont bernard et demi ça va
bien mieux physiquement ça va moins bien
face à va toujours pas terrible
moralement mais bon c'est dur c'est dur
il ya une solidarité magnifique de
certaines personnes et à ce moment là tu
te dis mais il ya d'autres gens qui
vivent ça c'est qu'ils n'ont pas cette
chance
entre guillemets d'être dans la lumière
et vision dans la misère tous les deux
et ils se font à veiller avec light dans
les yeux coups de batte directs
indirects et il avait cette espèce
d'obsession qui hantent apparemment
beaucoup de monde c'est de savoir où
était le coffre fort et ma mère ils ont
attaché les mains et il l'a traînée dans
la maison par les cheveux en
en lui hurlant de de montrer où était le
coffre qui amènera de coffre et à chaque
fois qu'elle répondait non elle en
prenait tapis sont quatre dont trois
africains et un de type nord-africain le
même bernard tapie qui accusait jean
marie le pen ce mensonge sur le lien
entre insécurité invasion de battoir il
est aujourd'hui rattrapé par la réalité
bon état bution sa jambe s'est indigné
j'ai juste l'impression de lui faire
c'est qu'ils se souviennent d'eux qui a
sauvé les gens dans l'hyper cacher sur
les attentats de charlie hebdo bien sûr
voilà c'était un immigré nord-africains
donc l'or suit la logique était
naturalisé d'ailleurs été naturalisé
l'adorent son geste messia pas chez toi
et tes yeux et il ya un truc aussi avec
toi on n'arrive pas il ya un moment où
tout le monde essaie de savoir avec qui
tu es avec lui pas site amoureuse
n'étais pas amoureuse non mais amy chua
non non il n'ya rien n'est pas chaud
c'est mon pote
vraiment je vous jure que sur un truc je
leur ai déclaré mais y'a vraiment rien
de dire aujourd'hui que célibataire oui
je sais le faire tant sa tournée sur les
réseaux on a parlé aussi de just ryad
aussi j'embrasse mon frérot voilà dans
mon temps on voit la vue avec tout le
monde
elle est célibataire lâché là elle est
dans la musique est ce qu'elle est dans
l'air du temps donc tout le monde
forcément leur était une aventure avec
les temps et les autres ben oui mais
vous vous avez été dans l'air du temps
vous avez il voulait juste se retourner
chez ses parents
donc on va en 2007 au mois de mars mais
en fait il a été il a été arrêté juste
parce qu'il était musulman c'est bien
sûr voilà quand il est arrivé chez ses
parents pour qu'ils ont arrêtés il ya
les policiers qui sont venu d'arrêter
emprise plusieurs mails sans nombre ils
ont arrêté subi des brimades et
humiliations
oui c'est surtout donc c'est pas tout de
suite au camp donc d'abord il était dans
un prison
donc pourquoi il est il montre les
chaînes au sort donc il à rester avec
les chaînes comme ça attaché il pouvait
bouger juste maximum à 1 m 3 mois il
donc il était subi toutes les tortures
qu on peut dire et après qu'ils ont
amené votre part très peu de gens
parlent
voilà la serna l'est quelques lanceurs
d'alertés vraiment c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe là bas mais c'est tout
c'est encore à cause de l'économie à
cause de l'argent non pas parce qu'il ya
c'est à dire c'est à dire qu'il ya 83
multinationales ce qu'ils utilisent des
travaux forcés des ouïghours il ya des
milliers des gens oui pour avoir loué
mais parce que tous les camps qu'ils
sont situés près de fabrique chez fred
des usines de vêtements donc voilà mes
vêtements de tous donc la main d'oeuvre
la même pour le fonds ne soit guînes par
exemple cette communauté ne représente
plus de 11 millions de personnes en
chine à lewiston alors vous avez vu ça
en bas oui oui père jean excuse moi ça
écoute non pas du tout cette soirée il
ya des neuf personnes y avait une autre
personne il y en a des 40es faut dire la
vérité marge en jetons plus y en avait
neuf où il y en avait 40 des personnes
je t'en parle je t'entends pas les gens
n'avaient pas 40 ça c'est clair et au
maximum écoute j'ai dû avoir une
quinzaine ou une vingtaine de personnes
au maximum
et bien non je suis désolé il n'y avait
pas deux mains ed membres du
gouvernement chez moi c'est me donner
une grande importance je le répète je le
dis il n'y avait pas de membre du
gouvernement lors de cette présentation
je ne fais pas de soirée ça fait 15 mois
cyril que je suis sans malheureusement
pouvoir organiser des soirées quoi que
ce soit au palais du yen c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'avais organisé
jeudi dernier cette présentation à 17h30
jean est ce que c'était payant parce
qu'on a vu 220 euros
c'était payant ou pas rien excuse moi je
t'entends quand est-ce que c'était
payant l'effort de laisser ton téléphone
est juste d'être toi la personne que tu
es qua non en france très honnêtement
vieillir on a fait un facebook l'arrêt
après avec tous les intervenants est
vraiment le kiff de cette émission c'est
que ça redonne de vraiment de l'espoir
sur l'ecc sur les liens humains sur tes
trucs bien que ce soit en france tu
aussi c'est ça les ordures moi aussi de
rester en france
voilà sa voix c'était un truc c'était
c'est une émission c'est une espèce
d'aude à la française
en revanche je pense que le fait
d'actualité il était mal choisie parce
que l'agression de bernard tapie ya rien
à dire à part que c'est abject et que
ces terribles s'attaquer à quelqu'un qui
souffre et qui qui s'attaque à quelqu'un
mais déjà tout court mais qui luttent
contre la maladie c'est encore pire
c'est terrible donc je trouve que le
fait d'actualité n'était pas très bien
choisis et j'ai l'impression que ça vous
a mis un peu mal à l'aise puisque
pendant l'émission vous avez écrit à
cyril est ce que vous avez regretté
déjà au moment où vous l'avez posté non
parce que dans mon tout et tout le monde
a oublié que j'ai quand même souhaité
amour établi lorsque l'immigration eto'o
est au coeur d'un acte héroïque on palpe
immédiatement dan immigrés maliens
quand il ya eu les on a parlé de lassana
batelli dondon dont me dont le dont
stéphane tapie a parlé hier lorsqu'il a
commis son acte héroïque qui par
ailleurs contesté tout le monde
arrêté et condamné cette année c'est
anne émigrés maliens c'est un immigré
s'éteint c'est un malien d'origine
on a stigmatisé on l'a on a focalisé sur
sa couleur de peau alors je vois pas
pourquoi lorsque l'immigration soit elle
et victimaire soit elle est héroïque on
peut en parler immédiatement il ya
toujours aucune décence et aucune
récupération et aucune
instrumentalisation et dès qu'il s'agit
d'une immigration tortionnaires
délinquante ou violente
il faut la terre il y avait le 9
septembre 2015 j'ai fait une tentative
de suicide et j'étais hospitalisée à
l'hôpital psychiatrique de montpellier à
lapeyronie
pourquoi t'as faim tu en déduit de
suicides qu'est ce qui se passait parce
qu'en fait je quand je vivais je suis né
avec quinze ans à ça oui j'ai j'avais 15
ans g lors des deux matchs du divorce de
mes deux parents
j'ai choisi de partir vivre avec mon
père ce qui est encore la plus grosse
erreur de pasteur ci est mon père m'a
terrorisée d'appeler ma mère
m'interdisais d'appeler mes soeurs et
surtout m'interdisais d'appeler ma grand
mère maternelle et demain sur avril il
va avoir un rendez vous avec un monsieur
qui est qui va qui vont se rencontrer
pour te former voilà je viens d'avoir
l'info d'en prendre à d'autres c'est pas
très grave donc demain tu va les
rencontrer
il a été touché par par ton témoignage
et voilà
vous arrivez vous préparez et où ensuite
il ya eu combien d'invités qui sont
arrivés alors au début ça va au
compte-gouttes n'a pas tout le monde qui
arrive à 17h30
c'est un petit acte il désirait vraiment
vers 20h30 21h c'est là où vraiment la
salle était pleine vous aurez une
quarantaine de convives
il paraît qu'il ya un animateur télé
noir je suis pas et sa liste des médias
j'ai une mauvaise mémoire mais j'ai
reconnu le directement une personne
c'est un animateur télé
un animateur qui a bercé mon enfance et
il y avait d'autres gens de la télé
une autre personnalité que je
connaissais moi mais j'avais déjà vu
comme un chroniqueur coincer un
chroniqueur à chroniquer rozic quand je
me sens en forme et je sais que ça en
chroniqueur est si bas qu'ils
travaillent encore en ce moment ils
disent qu'ils avaient un ministre dans
cette soirée
alors effectivement et avait un homme
politique
d'accord la presse ezzat un homme
politique sortant aux politiques moi je
suis chinoise vous savez pas c'est un
ministre ou pas non mais bon on vous a
dit que pour moi qu'est-ce qu'on vous
n'êtes pas dans le serveur on se brise
un petit peu ouais et on nous a dit
attention à cette table à c'est un homme
politique
donc faites attention à la manière de
servir à la manière des parallèles pensé
passer l'entretien si belle écoute assez
assez assez émouvant mais équipes sont
pliés en quatre pour essayer de trouver
une solution parce qu'on a fait ça
évidemment à bâtons rompus entre hier
soir et ce matin il s'est passé plein de
trucs pour nous de ce matin on a appris
en entretien avec le service rh
c'est un garçon évidemment quand on le
voit on a envie de on a envie de l'aider
on a envie de donner un coup de main à
19 ans c'est pas normal d'être à la rue
même s'ils font plaisir ils sont super
sympas hilare il a un garçon qui a de
l'ambition qui a des valeurs
je tiens à remercier et remercier toi
aussi série de m'avoir laissé venir sur
le plateau
une dizaine de policiers ont débarqué au
palais vivienne chez pierre jean chalon
sont ils sont allés semblablement venu
faire une perquisition et récupérer des
documents
regardez les images voila voila regarder
ça prend des proportions incroyables sa
pierre jean chalon sont qui a été arrêté
vers 18 heures il est sorti par une
porte à l'arrière du bar d'un bâtiment
embarqué par les forces de l'ordre
je vais arriver à 22 heures je ne sais
pas s'il ya une soirée moi j'ai vu grand
maximum une dizaine de personnes je ne
peux pas dire qu'il y avait autant de
monde
il y avait des tables dressées avec des
lois dites moi monsieur challans on m'a
mis dans une pierre et des restes de
prélim il n'y avait pas de restes de
repas de quoi que ce soit moi j'ai
simplement fait j'avais d'accord ni
drogue ni repas ni quoi que ce soit moi
j'ai entendu venu pour pour donner mon
contact chez une personne sans histoire
voilà